[Musique]
bienvenue sur le plateau d' interdit
d'interdire on veut passer toute cette
émission avec jean michel aphatie qui
publie à l'occasion du 50e anniversaire
de la mort de charles de gaulle le
dernier cadeau du général chez
flammarion un livre passionnant sur de
gaulle et sur sa volonté contre presque
tout le personnel politique à l'époque
on est en 1962 d' instaurer l'élection
du président de la république au
suffrage universel mais l'on commence
d'abord par notre époque qu'est ce qui
symbolise ce début de xxième siècle
voilà l'image que vous avez choisi jean
michel c'est le président de la
république emmanuel macron face à l'as
douanes
oui c'est une image qui demande une
explication nous vivons dans une
illusion intellectuelle collective nous
pensons que le retour des frontières
puisque le monde est tellement
inquiétant nous aidera à mieux maîtriser
notre destin
et quand on y réfléchit les grandes
crises auxquelles nous sommes confrontés
la crise écologique évidemment la crise
sanitaire le terrorisme aussi sont des
crises qui se moque des frontières et
des nationalités
évidemment la crise écologique que nous
la résoudrons que s'il y a des décisions
communes qui sont prises au niveau de la
planète
c'est la même chose pour la crise
sanitaire et la lutte contre le coc vide
et même le terrorisme suppose plutôt que
des douaniers qu'hypothétique m'en
arrêter des gens qui auraient des
mauvais calcul sur tel ou tel pays une
collaboration importante entre des
services secrets des appareils policiers
la syrie et la france pour parler de la
france la france et l'algérie
la france et l'egypte et donc les
frontières qui sont une espèce de corde
de rappel intellectuelle aujourd'hui
dans le débat
le retour de ceux des souverainetés ce
qui d'ailleurs nous ramène au général de
gaulle est une illusion d'optique parce
qu'aujourd'hui ce sont les énergies
qu'il faut fédérer au niveau de la
planète et nous sommes dans un
contresens total avec le réarmement la
réapparition de nos frontières
la contestation de la libre circulation
des individus
hélas s'il suffisait de quelques
douaniers pour régler nos problèmes ce
serait formidable nous tomberons de haut
quand vous
prendre on veut nous en à votre livre
jean michel aphatie le dernier cadeau du
général ce dernier cadeau pour vous
c'est l'élection du président de la
république au suffrage universel direct
qu'il a fait voter le général par un
référendum ont mis en octobre 1962 alors
est-ce qu'il s'agit bien d'un cadeau
parce que quand il s'agissait du général
de gaulle on élisait un roi et on en
était fier de ce roi
mais aujourd'hui pourquoi est-ce qu'on
pourrait parler de cadeau
parce que si l'on regarde l'histoire de
france dans sa totalité
quand les français nos ancêtres
abolissent la royauté c'est septembre
1792 et coupe la tête du roi 21 janvier
1793 à partir de ce moment là nous ne
savons plus organiser notre état et nous
ne savons plus donner une cohérence à
l'ordre politique qui doit gouverner la
france nous aurons essayer de
restauration une monarchie
constitutionnelle
trois républiques deux empires et rien
ne nous a satisfaits
si on regarde les pays européens autour
de nous il trouve beaucoup plus vite que
nous un équilibre politique est le
cadeau du général en 1962 c'est nous
permettre de renouer avec ce remords qui
habite notre inconscient avoir coupé la
tête du roi nous avons mal réglé le
problème de la monarchie nous l'avons
régler avec une violence que nous
n'avons jamais assumé et nous avons
ensuite cherché à travers les empires et
les restaurations à restaurer un pouvoir
fort est ce que la république semblait
empêcher de pouvoir faire c'est à dire
avoir un pouvoir à la tête de l'état
de gaulle a permis en faisant la réforme
de 1962 de gaulle répare on tente de
réparer cet immense cicatrices
psychologiques et c'est dans ce sens que
c'est un cadeau c'est en ce sens qu'à
mon avis aucun politicien ne reviendra
sur cette mesure cette réforme
l'élection du président de la république
au suffrage universel parce qu'elles
correspondent trop à ce que nous sommes
nous voulons élire notre roi et donc
nous voulons
battre notre roi ça c'est français bien
lorsque s qui était étonnant c'est à
quel point tout le personnel politique
quasiment en 1962 s'opposent à cette
réforme
alors les caciques de la quatrième
république évidemment dans nos noms
c'est donner trop d'importance à un
homme sous-entendu passé au parti
puisque c'était ça le régime des partis
de la 3e et de la 4e contre lequel
s'était débattue le général de gaulle
mais aussi des gens comme pierre mendès
france comme françois mitterrand comme
du mollet la gauche donc de l'époque
s'opposent de la même manière sous
l'angle c'est le coup d'état permanent
ces îles et il est quasiment tout seul
tout seul
les intellectuels les juristes les
journalistes les patrons de journaux il
n'y a pas un journal paris province qui
est engagée aux côtés du général
même le figaro de pierre brisson 10e est
ce que c'est une très bonne réforme même
genre un pompidou et hésitant alors il
va défendre la réforme du général sinon
il aurait quitté son poste
mais en privé il confie bien ses doutes
et ses hésitations et de gaulle confié à
l'un de ses ministres pierre sudreau qui
sera derrière démissionnaire parce que
lui aussi est hostile à cette réforme
de gaulle lui dira après mois personne
n'aurait eu le culot de faire ça et il a
raison parce que chez tous les
intellectuels si on prend ce vocable
large pour assembler tous les gens qui
ont un peu d'autorité dans la parole
publique chez tous les intellectuels
dans les années 60 c'est la pente de
l'égalité qui l'emportent sur la pente
de la distinction d'homme et de gaulle
lui par expérience personnelle notamment
quand il était militaire a toujours
pensé qu'il fallait à la tête de l'état
un chef sans quoi le malheur de juin 40
se reproduiraient est donc ce chef
puisque lui avait la légitimité
historique pour être chef de l'état à
partir de 58
ça ne posait pas de problème mais après
lui ce chef ne pouvait être distingué
que par le suffrage universel et donc
cette réforme là de gaulle impose à tout
le monde mais il impose pour longtemps
puisque encore aujourd'hui évidemment
nous continuerons distinguer
l'homme d'entre nous par le suffrage
universel alors il faut bien comprendre
que cette réforme du général de gaulle
elle se fait d'abord contre le parlement
puisque c'était le parlement par le
biais des grands électeurs qui
évidemment jusque-là votaient pour le
président de la république il les
milices pour cette raison-là illumine in
d'une deuxième manière parce qu'il va
proposer cette réforme aux français
directement par le biais d'un référendum
et c'est ça d'ailleurs que georges
pompidou conteste un peu vous raconter
dans votre livre il dit on est à la
limite de la légalité parce que
normalement il aurait dû le faire placer
devant l'assemblée nationale
non il ne le fait pas et vous ajouter un
troisième épisode rebondissements au
feuilleton sait qu à ce moment là
georges pompidou qui vient d'être nommé
premier ministre et pour la première
fois il a nommé un premier ministre qui
ne sort pas de la dérobée nationale qui
n'a jamais été élu et ce premier
ministre vient d'être renversé par
l'assemblée et à une fois le référendum
fait il y aura des aigles initiative
anticipé et il va renommer une georges
pompidou ce qui est contraire à tous les
usages s'ils avaient été renversées faut
le remplacer
eh bien non lay à l'est cette année 62
c'est la totale humiliation du parlement
par le général de gaulle
oui c'est ça c'est la totale domination
de domination de du législatif par
l'exécutif et au fond c'est ce que de
gaulle a toujours pensé
il a toujours pensé que la politique en
france devait être tiré déterminé par
l'exécutif
c'est contraire à ce que vivent toutes
les démocraties qui nous environne les
allemands les italiens les espagnols et
les britanniques
il se trouve c'est un trait culturel
qu'est ce qu'on peut contre la culture
peu de choses
le trait culturel c'est que dans les
régimes parlementaires dans les autres
pays européens en leadership peut
s'installer
angela merkel boris johnson tous les
dirigeants européens prennent leur
légitimité la source de la légitimité
c'est le parlement nous quand nous avons
essayé cela à partir de 1875 et de la
troisième république
on s'est rendu compte que ça ne marchait
pas que les parties et puis encore une
fois un substrat égalitaire
faisait que chaque tête qui dépassait
était renversé tous les gens qui avaient
un peu de talent même des france par
exemple paul reynaud tant d'autres
étaient systématiquement barré sur la
route du pouvoir et donc de gaulle
observateur très fin de la vie politique
dans les années 30 puis au dans les
années 40 en a conclu que la seule
manière de donner une tête à l'état
s'était déclaré le parlement et ce n'est
pas une réponse politique ou
politicienne
c'est une réponse à un problème culturel
sans cela la france n'est pas gouvernée
elles n'étaient pas gouvernés elle
n'aurait pas été gouvernée aujourd'hui
avoir un chef à la tête de l'état que
l'on peut battre
y'a pas de souci avec ça de toutes les
façons aucun président de la vème
république a été réélue sur l'action
qu'il a menée
donc les français ont de la distance par
rapport à ça ils ne sont pas écrasés par
la majesté du président mais c'est la
seule manière que pour un temps cinq ans
c'était cet en avant l'état soit dirigée
et c'est important que l'état soit
dirigée quand nous avons des grandes
crises affronter alors idée il ajoute en
plus une coquetterie que vous racontez
là encore dans le détail jean michel
aphatie c'est que pendant son discours
où il dit qu'il va plus qui veut un
référendum sur cette question dit qu'en
plus il va pas se contenter d'une
majorité médiocre il veut une vraie un
vrai vote d'adhésion parce que pour de
gaulle c'est ça être le chef de l'état
il faut qu'il y ait une adhésion et donc
il veut en gros qui est plus de 50% de
tous les inscrits donc si on compte les
bulletins blanc l'abstention qui veut
66%
il veut 66% et patatras il va obtenir
62% et il a failli de parvenir à les
viser bien sûr il explique que le 18
octobre c'est à dire dix jours avant le
référendum que si la médiocrité que si
la majorité des gens qui soutiennent sa
réforme est médiocre et aléatoires donc
si à moins de 50% des acides des
inscrits il en tire à tout de suite les
conséquences
le soir du 28 octobre il ya 47 % des
inscrits alors pour tourner le problème
comme vous
mais 47 c'est moins que 50 et il est
déprimé ce soir là et donc qui dit à
pompidou
je reste à colombes et je ne reviens pas
à paris et le monde du lendemain
après-midi sous titre saül en me disant
le général de gaulle dit cher à son
retour à l'elysée
nous sommes dans le début de la crise
politique et georges pompidou doit
prendre sa voiture
le lundi après midi parce que les modes
de transports de l'époque étaient ceux
là et il doit aller à colombes et et il
dit au général
enfin vous pouvez pas abandonner comme
ça mon général et le général qui peut
être ne demander que ça on ne sera
jamais se laisse convaincre et le
mercredi
il est de retour au conseil des
ministres mais il est très déprimée très
noir et et comme souvent il rappelait
français sont minables ils me
soutiennent pas ils ne comprennent pas
au fond les français ne mérite pas la
france mérite mais les français ne
mérite pas et pourtant il avait 62 % des
suffrages exprimés à ce qui est quand
même considérable et c'est là où je me
dis que ce cette élection du président
de la république au suffrage universel
et peut-être inquiète d'eau en poids
zone et parce que sorti du général de
gaulle puis de son successeur georges
pompidou qui tous les deux sont élus
avec au premier tour 44 % des voix à peu
près au premier tour donc là on voit
qu'il ya une véritable adhésion mais
c'est plus du tout le cas pour ces pour
ceux qui vont suivre avec valéry giscard
d'estaing au premier tour ça descend à
32% avec françois mitterrand ça descend
à 25% et aujourd'hui avec emmanuel
macron ça est descendu à 24% mais si
l'on s'en réfère aux barèmes du général
c'est à dire en fonction des inscrits ce
qui pour lui était le plus important on
descend pour et maniema croate 17%
c'est à dire que pour françois hollande
s'était 22% seulement pour nicolas
sarkozy s'était j'ai calculé 25% et le
pire c'est pour jacques chirac lui c'est
15%
si je me trompe pas non c'est oui c'est
15 15 9 16% à 895 et 13,75 % quand il
est réélu en 2000
de 13,75 % que peut-on faire quand on a
si peu d'adhésion et que donc une fois
passées les élections et que par la
magie de notre système on va avoir
souvent la majorité absolue des députés
mais on à 85% de la france qui est déjà
dans l'opposition
la démocratie ça n'est jamais la
perfection il faut choisir le moins
mauvais système ce que l'on a compris du
fonctionnement de la troisième de la
quatrième république rapportés à la
culture française c'est que les partis
politiques avaient une telle mainmise
sur le parlement je l' ai dit tout à
l'heure que concrètement aucun dirigeant
politique n'arrivait à s'imposer sur la
durée dans le paysage politique français
le pire du pire il a été atteint en 1956
le 2 janvier 1956 les français c'est la
quatrième république dans un système
politique et électoral complexe mais
parlementaires votent pour une majorité
de députés qui soutiennent l'action de
pierre mendès-france et pierre
mendès-france il l'habille vie pendant
sa campagne il est pour la paix en
algérie
voir il ne le dit pas comme ça mais ça
se déduit pour l'algérie algérienne
la femme de l'algérie française et une
majorité de français votent pour lui les
jeux parlementaires sont ce qu'ils sont
que le 31 janvier donc trente jours
après l'élection
c'est guy mollet qui sort président du
conseil par un artifice dont les partis
ont le secret mmd france ne sera plus
qu'un ministre de 10 mollet et bien de
guy mollet va faire la guerre en algérie
et nous sommes donc passés en 30 jours
de la volonté de paix à l'algérie à
l'effectivité de la guerre en algérie
c'est une tromperie du suffrage
universel qui est terrible c'est cela
qui fait dire que les régimes
parlementaires en france ont été un
naufrage et donc le régime présidentiel
ap
mis au français de se réconcilier ça
n'est pas rien avec la démocratie au
moins le paysage politique est claire on
sait pour qui on vote et on sait qui
aura le pouvoir
le plus terrible ce serait d'abandonner
l'élection du président de la république
au suffrage universel qui a les défauts
que vous signalez oui comment les les
corriger je ne sais pas bien sûr que
cette élection a des défauts mais si
nous abandonnions nous prendrions le
risque de retomber dans des travers qui
susciterait un tel mécontentement que
nous en payons le prix de la démocratie
et je trouve que là dessus nous n'avons
pas les idées claires nous ne regardons
pas l'histoire et nous ne tirons pas des
leçons de l'histoire c'est quand même un
problème parce que je vois bien que
l'élection présidentielle fatigue et se
fatigue en sortir ce serait une erreur
magistrale
néanmoins pour le cas que vous citez
l'élection du mollet pour le plaisir de
la conversation il faut rappeler que lee
mollet avait été élu comme pierre
mendès-france c'était la même liste
c'était le front républicain qui se
présente avec le programme que vous avez
dit finalement c'est guy mollet parce
qu'il ya aussi le président de la
république à l'époque qui a son mot à
dire et qui préfère visiblement limonest
à pierre mendès france
il va appeler dix mollet et guy mollet
va en algérie se prend une volée de
tomates de la part des colons algérien
et retourne sa veste donne les pleins
pouvoirs à l'armée votre le service
militaire à 28 mois et double les
effectifs militaires en algérie mais
parce qu'il a retourné sa veste
c'est ça n'est pas c'est fait il y la
renier même ce qu'il pensait avant
c'était une c'était un faible et sans
doute un imbécile aussi peut-être mais
non je pense pas non non c'est pas bon
je pense que guy mollet non mais c'est
alors pour le coup c'est très
intéressant
guy mollet était au contraire un homme
qui avait le sens de l'état et un homme
tel que j'ai pu le percevoir au travers
des livres parce qu'évidemment je ne
vais pas connu un homme qui avait une
grande intelligence politique mais vous
avez dit le monde
on découvre le 6 février 1956 qu'il est
faible psychologiquement guy mollet et
friable et il est tellement effrayée par
le spectacle des français en algérie qui
ont failli le lyncher littéralement il
est attrapé par l'armée devant le
monument aux morts d'alger à quelques
secondes de près il pouvait lui arriver
vraiment des grandes misères à guy
mollet il est tellement émue il est
tellement émotif qu'il change
complètement de politique sur l'algérie
sa tenue à ça la guerre d'algérie vous
vous rendez compte un peu c'était les
voyelles et c'est là où nous toujours
pour le plaisir de la conversation c'est
là où là la constitution de la vème
république ne change pas grand-chose à
ça c'est que une fois qu'on a été élu et
qu'on a tous les pouvoirs que les
cinquièmes nous donne en tant que
président de la république
on peut parfaitement changer de
politique on peut exactement faire le
contraire de ce pour quoi on a été élu
personne ne viendra vous dire quoi que
ce soit aucun contre-pouvoir ne vous
dira ah là je suis désolé ça n'est pas
ce que vous nous aviez promis vous le
savez bien
et donc la cinquième n'a pas résolu le
problème
jacques chirac par exemple passé le
contraire de ce qu'il avait laissé
entendre qu'il ferait avant d'être élu
françois mitterrand aussi d'une certaine
manière il ya alors vous n'avez pas tort
la perfection n'existe pas dans la
politique voilà alors il se trouve que
votre livre est aussi un livre sur le
général de gaulle
notre grand homme donc c'est fascinant
de voir aujourd'hui 50 50 ans après sa
mort qu'il n'ya plus d'anti gaulliste en
france quasiment même ses plus acharnés
ennemis qui sont encore vivants
aujourd'hui le vénère je ne citerai pas
de noms mais la liste est et la liste
est très longue
c'est vraiment l'éternel revenant et ça
commence quasiment comme ça la vie de
charles de gaulle puisque vous rappeler
ce qu'on a beaucoup pour oublier c'est
qu'il est il est déclaré mort
officiellement à l'âge de 25 ans par la
bataille de verdun ses parents portent
le deuil
tout le monde pense que le capitaine de
gaulle est mort et il reviendra et
puisque en fait on s'aperçoit au bout de
quelques temps qu'en fait il est
prisonnier des allemands mais déjà ça
commence il revient
il revient listo l'histoire est quand
même assez formidable et ironique donc
on est le 3 mars 1916 le combat en début
d'après midi entre les fantassins
français puisque de gaulle et dans
l'infanterie et les fantassins
l'allemand se fait à la baïonnette de
gaulle à tuer des allemands à l'épée
c'est incroyable ça et puis il disparaît
et donc on pense qu'il est mort et le
général de brigade de l'époque c'est la
tradition publie un éloge nécrologique
du capitaine de gaulle et ce général
d'armée c'est philippe pétain c'est
incroyable mais qui dit le capitaine de
gaulle est mort quelle perte pour la
france que le perte pour l'armée que le
perte pour l'humanité
avec le recul évidemment voir que le
général pétain a signé ces lignes c'est
quand même assez savoureux et de gaulle
est sauvé par les allemands parce que il
y à 80% des officiers de l'infanterie
française qui sont morts pendant la
guerre de 14 18
c'est la troisième blessure de de gaulle
pendant la guerre de 14 18
ce 3 mars 1916 s'il en avait réchappé
s'il était resté un blessé sur le
terrain et si les français l'avaient les
récupérer s'ils étaient repartis au
combat
probablement statistiquement en tout cas
au reptile était mort d'une certaine
manière les allemands sauver de gaulle
alors de gaulle salué par pétain en 1916
est sauvé par les allemands
reconnaissait que quand même même un
auteur de pièces de théâtre elle imagine
pas celle là alors il et il est génial
de gaulle il est d'une intelligence
extraordinaire il est surtout c'est sa
faculté d'anticipation qui moi
m'impressionne
en juin 40 au moment où il fait son son
discours il a déjà compris tout ce qui
va se passer par la suite il a compris
que la guerre va devenir mondial il a
compris que les américains vont se
ranger aux côtés des onglets des
français il a compris que la le pacte de
non-agression entre les allemands et les
russes va très vite cédé il a tout vu
entre juin 40 il sait ce qu'ils veulent
ce que va être l'avenir et y en a pas
beaucoup et j'ai toujours pensé que ce
nom
la raison pour laquelle françois
mitterrand avait toujours détesté le
général de gaulle c'est que lui alors
qu'il est plus jeune s'est trompé
mitterrand pendant le début de la guerre
crois que l'allemagne a gagné la guerre
que c'est réglé et tout à coup il va se
rendre compte que ce type là
cette vieille ganache militaire en
réalité a vu beaucoup plus loin que lui
je pense qu'il ne lui en voudra toute sa
vie c'est assez juste de penser qu'il ya
une une jalousie profonde du plus jeune
à l'égard de l'aîné oui c'est assez
juste
churchill avait compris ça comme de
gaulle quand vous dites qu'ils étaient
très peu à l'avoir compris vous avez
raison mais dans le livre je raconte
aussi parce que l'aventuré de de gaulle
tient à peu de choses le 13 juin 1940 de
gaulle qui a établi un contact avec
churchill parce que celui qui préside le
gouvernement français paul reynaud et de
gaulle en quelque sorte et le porte
parole de paul reynaud auprès de
churchill à londres c'est comme ça que
le contact se fait pas ce que de gaulle
personne ne le connaît donc à partir du
9 juin de gaulle est fait l'aller-retour
londres paris puis londres bordeaux en
fonction de l'avancée de l'armée
allemande pour entretenir le dialogue
entre un churchill et raynaud le 13 juin
de gaulle comprend que rénova capituler
et que c'est petén qui prendra la suite
et donc de gaulle est prêt à
démissionner du gouvernement et à ce
moment là un acteur que l'on a un peu
oublié qui est ministre de l'intérieur à
l'époque et moi-même j'oublie son nom à
l'époque mais évidemment il est mort
georges mandel voilà un ancien
collaborateur de georges clemenceau
mandel fait venir de gaulle dans son
bureau le soir du 13 juin 1940 et il lui
dit j'ai appris général que vous vouliez
démissionner ne fait pas ça continuer à
travailler à partir du gouvernement
français continue et dialoguer avec les
anglais si vous êtes tout seul dans la
nature et vous n'aurez plus aucun moyen
d'action et c'est georges mandel qui
sauve le 18 juin 40
cette aventure de de gaulle etienne rien
et de gaulle dans ses mémoires dira
j'étais impressionné il n'y a qu'à
propos de cela qu il le dit d'ailleurs
j'ai été impressionné par georges mandel
et par son raisonnement et j'ai remis ma
lettre de démission dans la poche s'il
n'avait pas croisé la route de mende
elle le soir du 13 juin
il y aurait pas eu le 18 juin c'est
extraordinaire quand même l'histoire
tient à rien il faut rappeler que les
débits chaussée la démission du
gouvernement puisqu'il est sous
secrétaire d'état à la défense le
général de gaulle à ce moment là c'est
ça il avait été nommé par un paul
reynaud et georges mandel
malheureusement sera fusillé par en face
sera exécuté par par la milice pendant
pendant l'occupation
ce qui est ce qui est fascinant chez de
gaulle c'est qu'on voit bien qui ne
transige pas un il ne transige jamais on
l'a vu le soir de du référendum sur
l'élection du du président de la
république au suffrage universel
en juin 40 c'est pareil ne transige pas
alors ça peut être un avantage ou un
inconvénient je propose de faire une
petite pause on se retrouve juste après
il ya un exemple quand même on se dit
las il avait pas transit si quelqu'un
d'autre taille pas transiger pour lui ça
a peut-être pu mal tourner c'est mai 68
on va voir ça juste après
[Musique]
c'est donc avec jean michel aphatie que
l'on commémore le 50e anniversaire de la
mort de charles de gaulle jean michel
aphatie qui lui consacre un livre le
dernier cadeau du général aux éditions
flammarion le dernier cadeau ce serait
l'élection du suffrage au suffrage
universel du président de la république
mais je les dis c'est aussi un livre sur
le général de gaulle
on était en train de dire qu'il ne
transigerait jamais le général de gaulle
et ses impressions qu'ils donnent et
comme il a souvent raison c'est très
bien de ne pas transiger mais quand on a
tort c'est plus un problème est sans
doute en mai 68
si georges pompidou n'avait pas
transiger et le général d'ailleurs lui
en voudra d'avoir transiger ça aurait
sans doute mal tourné ne le pensez vous
pas ah oui bien sûr le général était
favorable à l'évacuation par la force
les policiers les militaires ne s'est
pas de la sorbonne en mai 1968 s'il
avait fait ça mai 68 aurait pris un
tournant très différent et ça aurait pu
être un bain de sang en fait donc
évidemment il est heureux que georges
pompidou est pris la main mais quand
j'ai parlé du dernier cadeau du général
le qualificatif dernier dans mon esprit
a un sens je trouve que c'est un peu la
dernière chose que réussie le général le
général de gaulle c'est le 18 juin 40
c'est l'association de la france à la
libération avec les grandes puissances
alors que la france en a objectivement
moins fait que tous les autres pays
c'est éviter à la france
la guerre civile à propos de l'algérie
et puis il ya les réformes des
institutions
après il ya plus grand-chose de gaulle a
du mal à comprendre la société dans
laquelle il vit
il y à un conflit avec les mineurs en 63
kg mais en difficulté
il est obligé de rapporter un décret de
réquisition l'élection présidentielle de
1965 de gaulle je pense que ça va être
facile pour lui il est contraint au
ballottage en 1967 les élections
législatives se joue à une voix il est
sur le fil du rasoir le général il ya
bien longtemps qu'il n'a plus compris la
société
qu'ils étaient chargés diriger et on
peut même dire les choses différemment
son rôle historique c'est facile à dire
après puis ça fait un peu grandiloquent
mais son rôle historique s'est arrêtée
en octobre 62
après c'est de la gestion qui n'est pas
exceptionnel et donc mai 68
toute cette jeunesse qui se rebellent il
ne la comprend pas même s'il a eu
l'occasion
ça n'est pas rien d'avoir reçu johnny
hallyday le le chef de file des yéyés
qui est en train d'enflammer la jeunesse
française qui est en fait un gentil
garçon johnny hallyday bien sûr même
dans les années 60 c'est joli il a les
cheveux longs mais c'est antoine qui
disait dans les idées courtes bon de
gori connaît johnny il aime bien je n'y
trouve que seul type sympa mais de
gaulle ne comprend pas du tout la
jeunesse française
et heureusement qu'il ya pompidou parce
que pompidou c'est un hédoniste quand il
était à matignon il ya les en porsche
vous imaginez aujourd'hui un premier
ministre allait en porsche à matignon
pompidou y comprends pas ce que pompidou
ils partagent pompidou oui c'est un
jouisseur pompidou ce que de gaulle n'a
jamais été et donc pompidou exprime
beaucoup mieux mai 68 que de gaulle et
pompidou en mai 68 c'est pour de gaulle
à figures vivantes de ces la ferme
alors comment on se raconte l'histoire
de manière romanesque on me dira le
général a chuté sur le référendum mais
pas du tout général ya bien longtemps
qu'il a chuté il ya bien longtemps qui
comprend plus la france le général a
aimé la france mais la france lui a
échappé alors il faut bien se souvenir
aussi qu'en mai 68 le général de gaulle
à 75 ans qu'il a vécu deux guerres
mondiales
il est dans une idée de l'effort
d'ailleurs il demande tout le temps aux
français des efforts il n'est pas du
tout à même on peut l'imaginer de
comprendre la genèse des années 60 mais
je vous trouve un peu sévère quand même
avec son avec son action
à savoir qu'il va faire des choses
extraordinaires encore le plan calcul
c'est extraordinaire ce libellé à
giscard d'estaing n'y avait pas mis fin
quand il a été élu
les français auraient peut-être inventé
internet on était très en avance sur les
américains grâce au plan calcul grâce au
général de gaulle toute la politique
industrielle sous georges pompidou qui
étaient très intelligents et formidable
aussi on est la première puissance
économique en europe
c'est le résultat de leurs deux
politiques conjuguées additionnés c'est
une vraie réussite sur le plan
économique sur à peu près tous les plans
sur le plan des moeurs ou effectivement
il comprend pas la jeunesse des années
mais encore une fois ce thème que
monsieur qui vient d'un autre monde il
est né au 19e siècle de gueule
nous n'avons peut-être pas la même
perception
une fois que le travail institutionnel
est fait est que l'algérie est rendu à
son destin de gaulle ensuite se banalise
vous parlez du plan calcul mais ce n'est
pas la hauteur de de gaulle le plan
calcul c'est bien que ce qui au fond si
je peux être trivial
qu'est-ce qu'ils sont fous de vols de
gol ce qu'il aime c'est chateaubriand
c'est par le plan calcul bon on lui dit
il faut faire le plan calcul il fait le
plan calcul d'ailleurs à saint cyr
je suis plus comment on appelle ça mais
il n'avait pas de très bonnes notes en
le tir en mathématiques ce qui fait
qu'ils pouvaient pas les dans
l'artillerie
je voulais le plan calcul ministre
intelligent lui a dit général il faut
faire un plan calcul il fait un plan
calcul mais de gaulle se banalise
encore une fois comme le chantier
institutionnel est terminée ce kit le
chantier un site institutionnel c'est à
l'échelle de l'histoire alors fois parce
que ça nous accompagne encore mais aussi
parce que c'est un pan avec ce régime
que nous avons adoré et qui était la
royauté et quand de gaulle à chiny ça
bon il aurait pu
c'étaient ceux qui lui disaient ivoire
n'est d'ailleurs enfin charles il faut
arrêter et il aurait pu arrêter son
histoire était fait
elle était écrite alors j'ai pas tout à
fait d'accord avec vous parce qu'il
avait quand même l'idée de
l'indépendance nationale et le plan
calcul c'est la réponse est quelque
chose qui le tracasse c'est à dire qui
sait il comprend que l'informatique va
avoir de l'importance
il ne veut pas que les américains soient
les
sur le sur ce terrain et que donc si on
lui dit qu'avec un plan calcul il peut
résoudre le problème il adopte le plan
calcul
il comprend ce qui comprend que
l'informatique faut pas rigoler avec
mais revenons à votre livre parce que
j'ai découvert énormément de choses
vous écrivez notamment un chapitre sur
le bourbier algérien c'est le titre que
vous le lui donner un chapitre
particulièrement cruel avec notre
politique coloniale notre politique en
algérie et cela depuis le début un dès
la conquête pour vous tout ça et quand
le jour stupide incohérent criminelle en
se
on se couvre de honte du début jusqu'à
la fin j'ai j'ai trouvé cette belle
carte postale sur nos belles colonie
l'algérie française ça n'est pas du tout
cette carte postale là évidemment et
c'est pour ça que ça va que ça va
devenir ce que c'est devenu à partir de
1954 et on a tendance à oublier
aujourd'hui ce qui va déclencher le
retour du poète du général de gaulle qui
est temps que depuis 12 ans qui a quitté
le pouvoir en 1946 déjà là il refusé de
transiger
il est parti et donc en 1958 ce qui va
déclencher le retour du général de
gaulle vous le raconter c'est le
bombardement d'un village en tunisie par
les avions français les avions de chasse
les bombardiers on va quand même
bombardé un village tunisien pâle j'ai
rien tunisien on va tuer des hommes des
femmes des enfants des vieillards on va
voilà voilà les photos et c'est ça qui
va déclencher le retour du général de
gaulle au pouvoir on l'a complètement
oublié alors racontez nous pourquoi
ah oui c'est un épisode méconnu
aujourd'hui en février 1958 alors que le
fln le front de libération nationale
algérien cause des pertes douloureuses
et de manière sauvage aux armées
françaises en février 1958
en quelques minutes le commandement
français en algérie décide de bombarder
le camp du fln qui est située dans le
village de sac
et de l'autre côté de la frontière
algérienne dans le pays souverain depuis
deux ans de la tunisie et c'est un
bombardement il ya 25 avions qui
participent aux bombardements qui est
mal fait parce que une partie du camp du
fln sera détruit mais des bombes tombent
sur le marché de sa quille et tuent des
femmes des hommes des enfants des civils
tunisiens et une partie des bombes
tombent sur une école tunisienne hélas
il y a une cinquantaine je crois de
petit temps de petits enfants tunisiens
qui meurent sous les bombes françaises
et ce bombardement là a pour effet alors
que jusque là tout le monde de regarder
l'algérie comme une affaire intérieure à
la france d' internationaliser le
problème algérienne les anglais les
américains les russes tout le monde s'en
mêle et le pouvoir de l'époque dirigé
par félix gaillard est obligé de
consentir une mission de bons offices
entre la tunisie et la france aux anglo
american et c'est à partir de là que le
gouvernement français ne va plus
maîtriser la situation en algérie
c'est à partir de là que les militaires
français en algérie vont avoir le
sentiment que le gouvernement français
prépare l'abandon de l'algérie puisqu'il
laisse les américaines les anglais
mettre leur nez dans nos affaires et
c'est à partir de là que salon massue et
ses copains commencent à imaginer un
comité de salut public
alger pour amener au pouvoir le général
de gaulle sur un mot d'ordre algérie
française et de gaulle depuis le
bombardement de sakiet c'est à dire
depuis le jour où ça qui a été bombardé
de gaulle regarde la situation
comprendre qu'il tire son épingle du jeu
ou qu'il peut l'attiré et il l'est se
dire à tous les gaullistes qui sont à
alger qu'il est favorable à l'algérie
française
alors qu'il ne l'a jamais été de gaulle
selon tous les témoignages qui sont
apparues après en privé dit
et l'algérie elle serait algérienne ça
ne peut pas être autrement
ne serait ce que pour des raisons
démographiques et donc de gaulle
s'engage dans la dissimulation voire
même dans le mensonge pour que tous les
gaullistes d'alger accompagnent l'armée
dans l'acte de sédition qui va être le
leur
et c'est cela qui va permettre à de
gaulle et de revenir au pouvoir
presque un coup d'état est presque
mensonge on est quand même loin de du
général au dessus de toutes les
contingences humaines et de tous les
calculs politiques
on est là avec un général qui a les deux
mains dans le potage et qui va
allègrement
et qui dit aux hommes et aux autres ce
qu'ils ont envie d'entendre parce que
l'essentiel c'est qu'il revienne au
pouvoir mais il a les mains
effectivement plus que dans le potager
les a dans le cambouis mais en réalité
là où il est génial c'est ya pas de
trace quand il retire les mains il n'y a
pas de saleté sur les mains personne ne
le sait personne ne peut le prouver et
vous raconter tout alors sur ceux sur le
village tunisien le l'ambassadeur de
tunisie en france et rappelé par son
gouvernement et arrive à ce moment là
olivier guichard vieux gaulliste enfin
très jeune à l'époque olivier guichard
qu'on va voir apparaître ici il est un
peu oublié aujourd'hui mais il a été
ministre par la suite et il a l'idée
géniale d'invités de proposer à
l'ambassadeur de tunisie en france
d'aller voir le général à colombey ce
qu'ils devaient faire ça prend tout de
suite une ampleur considérable et puis
il ya d'autres gens qui s'agitent
derrière y aller on delbecq
par exemple que vous racontez aussi léon
delbecque qu'on va voir là lui c'est lui
c'est les pieds noirs qui sont derrière
lui et léon delbecque le jardin ne se
souviendra pas de l'avoir rencontré bien
entendu mais ils se rencontrent ils
parlent longuement il ne lui fais aucune
promesse
le général de gaulle mais évidemment
pour delbecque comme pour tous les pieds
noirs de gaulle est favorable à
l'algérie française de gaulle est
favorable à l'armée et delbecque va
entraîner jusqu'à au général salan qui
sera ensuite celui qui va essayer de
renverser le général de gaulle en avril
61 mais avant cela elle qui sera même à
chef de l' os
mais avant cela il va appeler de gaulle
lui aussi il les a tous formidablement
utilisé
c'est tout ça ce sont des histoires
formidables ça qui est bombardé le
samedi à 10h30 et le hasard veut qu
olivier guichard dont vous avez parlé et
tu te sois là hésiter d'une soirée
parisienne parce que tu cherches un peu
les yeux les oreilles de de gaulle il
était chef de la vieille officiellement
dans le plat petit intelligentia
parisienne le samedi soir il est invité
chez un journaliste parisien et il y à
l'ambassadeur de tunisie qui est un
jeune homme de 35 ans qui est aussi dans
cette soirée et dix chars ennemis
l'élimination élus ni pourquoi on
n'irait pas voir de gaulle ensemble
demain et la faire se fait tout de suite
le ce dimanche soir l'ambassadeur
tunisien est à colombey-les-deux-églises
le lundi de golf et publié par la lfp un
communiqué alors que de gaulle mais rien
et que de gaulle et silencieux depuis
plusieurs années ils ne parlent plus sur
le paysage politique français de golf et
publié par l'intermédiaire de la sp un
communiqué j'ai reçu l'ambassadeur de
tunisie en france
ah bon alors quel titre j'ai reçu
l'ambassadeur je lui dis de faire passer
le message au président bourguiba
surtout ne gâchez pas les relations avec
la france une solution sera trouvée et
je me tiens à la disposition de tout le
monde pour régler cette affaire et qui
quand même à prendre une vilaine
tournure et au gouvernement français
donc c'est toujours félix gaillard kenzy
mais qu'est-ce qui fait le général et ça
c'est le début de la mise en mouvement
du général qui dira ah les hommes
delbecque qui viendra le voir à ce
moment là il ne lui dit pas le général
ne dit pas delbecque je suis pour
l'algérie française
il lui dit mais enfin delbecq vous
imaginez le général lâché un bond du
territoire de la france
il s'arrête là de gaulle edel mais qui
sort du bureau de de gaulle c'est aussi
rue de solférino à paris
il sort du bureau disant le général et
pour l'algérie française
mais lui a pas du tout dit ça le général
et donc delbecque qui va faire pression
sur les militaires
parce que delbecque connais très bien
tous les militaires d'alger et jusqu'à
pousser le général massu on est le 15
mai alger
le coup d'état a eu lieu le putsch
militaire et le coup d'état on l'appelle
comme on veut le 13 mai mais les
militaires ils savent plus quoi faire du
pouvoir qu'ils ont pris à alger
ils ont viré le résident général il
occupe le gouvernement que général mais
ils ne savent pas quoi faire et salan
même pas de gaulle et il a une réticence
officiel de google
il sent bien que de gaulle et pas franc
du collier et il sent bien que l'algérie
française de gaulle
il n'est pas là dessus mais delbecque
très finement va amener sa lente parce
que salon est épuisé psychologiquement
il dirige les militaires mais les
militaires ne savent plus quoi faire
il va pousser ça là on le 15 mai 58 sur
le balcon du forum d'alger
salah ont fait un speech algérie
française pour toujours vive la
république vive la france
salle ansart est delbecque est derrière
lui et lui souffle à l'oreille et dit
vivre le général de gaulle et salons
vive le général de gaulle et à ce moment
là c'est parti
l'armée qui détient le pouvoir à alger
qui menaçait la république à paris se
range derrière le général après le
général il se frise il n'a plus qu'à
prendre le pouvoir il est il est tombé
par terre et alors ce qui est
extraordinaire c'est que la première
conférence de presse du général de
gaulle
on s'en souvient tous parce qu'on l'a en
forme se souvient tous
on l'a revu et revu celle à ces salles
où il dit je voulais quand même pas que
je commence une carrière de dictateur à
67 ans puisque toute la sphère que vous
venez de raconter évidemment n'est pas
trés trés mais pas si on avait voulu de
la transparence à l'époque serait pas
été génial s'il avait fallu deux tweeté
ça n'aurait pas été très bons non plus
donc tout ça n'est pas clair il ya
énormément de gens qui s'opposent au
retour du général de gaulle tous ceux
qui s'opposeront par la même occasion au
référendum sur la désignation du
président de la république au suffrage
universel c'est les mêmes et donc cette
conférence de presse que nous
connaissons tous n'a jamais été diffusée
la télévision c'est ça qui est
extraordinaire
en fait si on l'a si on la sait pas ce
qui a été filmé par la télévision
américaine
parce qu'à l'époque le général de gaulle
était interdit de radio est interdite
télé d'ailleurs il va garder cette bonne
attitude
tant que le général de gaulle sera
président de la république jamais
l'opposition n'aura accès à la
télévision ou à la radio
il faut bien le voir c'était à la radio
officielle j'entends alors rtf interdite
mitterrand
et toujours chercher des images de
mitterrand et le rts à van avant
l'arrivée de georges pompidou à l'elysée
c'est lui qui va ouvrir mais sinon avant
c'était impossible de gaulle créé le
rassemblement du peuple français donc un
parti politique au printemps 1947 et
quand il le crée donc on est en avril
le président du conseil de l'époque qui
s'appelle paul ramadier socialiste va
voir de gaulle à colombey et il lui dit
mon général vous venez de créer un parti
politique
vous n'aurez plus accès à la radio à la
télévision française qui est voué à
présenter l'action du gouvernement
puisque vous présentez comme un opposant
au gouvernement
vous serez censuré et de gaulle mais à
moitié ramadier dehors en lui disant je
vous ai pas entendu en 40
j'ai pas besoin de vous aujourd'hui
dehors ramadier met donc en 58 le 19 mai
1958 le gouvernement de l'époque
toujours dense et pierre flynn qui est
là maintenant présidente du conseil
c'est un socialiste dont j'oublie le nom
mais jamais revenir que ministre je le
mot-clé ministre de l'intérieur est bien
jules moch interdit à la télévision
française et à la radio de films et
d'enregistrer la conférence de presse
c'est inouï de penser ça de gaulle était
très car en france la presse écrite
rencontre de sa conférence de presse
mais les gens qui n'écoutent à l'époque
que la radio ou la télé ne savent pas du
tout que de gaulle s'est mis en route
pour revenir au pouvoir
c'est incroyable de gaulle censuré en
france alors après vous avez raison de
gaulle ne se vengera jeter les moeurs de
l'époque
enfin qu'on censure de gaulle c'est
quand même incroyable
et alors ce qu'il ya de formidable en
lisant votre livre jean michel aphatie
c'est qu'on s'aperçoit à quel point ça
n'a pas été un tapis de roses la
présidence de la république pour le pour
le général de gaulle on pourrait
l'imaginer
étant donné j'y reviens l'adhésion d'une
grande majorité des français à son
action le fait qu'il faisait des scores
extraordinaire de gaulle n'avait pas
besoin de faire campagne électorale tout
ça c'était ça n'existait pas si les
faits et et pourtant ils ne cessent de
se heurter à des oppositions souvent
violentes vous raconter aussi les
attentats qu'on prépare contre lui et
qui ont tous échoué
c'est quand même une une carrière
politique aujourd'hui on pourrait croire
qu'il a eu la belle vie pas du tout pas
une pas une minute alors pas du tout
c'est l'histoire à gommer tout ce que
charles de gaulle avait deux disruptif
et donc toutes les tensions qu'il
suscitait autour de lui même quand il
libère paris au mythe en août 1944 le 26
août 1944 il descend les champs elysées
il ya deux millions de personnes qui
l'acclament mais il ya déjà beaucoup de
gens qui le regardent avec méfiance mais
qu'est ce qu'il veut ce type là il a
déjà tout le pouvoir pourquoi il
organise un sacre comme ça il ya
toujours eu autour du général de gaulle
une peur et une crainte la crainte qu'il
ne devienne un dictateur et donc ça
s'accompagne charles de gaulle toute sa
vie en 58
il ne peut pas revenir pouvoir
normalement il a besoin des militaires
quand il a fini la sphère algérienne et
qu'il veut faire son référendum pour
élire le président de la république au
suffrage universel au beaucoup de gens
ne veulent pas de sa réforme parce
qu'ils ne peuvent que une fois installé
par le suffrage universel
sacralisé par ce référendum de gaulle ne
rendent jamais le pouvoir et la
référence qui est systématiquement
utilisée parce que les gens à l'époque
on est mort nous on n'a plus du tout
celle là mais c'est l'image de louis
napoléon qui est élu au suffrage
universel en 1848 et qui plutôt que de
repasser devant les électeurs à la fin
de son mandat c'est un coup d'état de
1851 et c'est tout ce substrat cette
mémoire cette douleur la volonté de ne
pas donner la république un seul homme
qui fait que charles de gaulle n'aura
jamais le repos nous avec le recul on
imagine qu'il était dominateur pas du
tout et jamais il a toujours dû se
battre et au fond il a adoré ça parce
que sinon vu son intelligence et et ses
capacités exceptionnelles
tout aurait été trop facile oui
d'ailleurs c'est votre c'est votre thèse
dans ce livre c'est qu'au fond ils
préfèrent la politique à tout le reste
ils préfèrent la politique et la vie
militaire et il est d'ailleurs
certainement bien meilleur pour la
politique que pollet pour la vie
militaire mais aujourd'hui 50 ans après
sa mort on adore tous le général de
gaulle j'ai dit il ya quasiment plus
d'opposants il était génial il avait
tout compris avant tout le monde
mais comme vous comme on l'a rappelé à
l'époque l'opposition n'a pas accès à
l'eau et rtf
le ministre de l'information fait le
programme du journal télévisée le soir
quand il fait des conférences de presse
une fois qu'on le laissera les faire le
général de gaulle il à l'écriture à
l'avance tout le monde le sait
et dans les questions on lui demande on
lui pose jamais de questions sur elf
on lui pose pas de questions sur la
françafrique on lui pose pas de
questions sur les polices parallèles
dieu sait s'ils en avaient sous le
gaullisme on lui pose pas de questions
sur les affaires un peu trouble on sait
que les juges à ce moment là sont aux
ordres du ministère de la justice qui
lui même est aux ordres du gouvernement
en tout cas du général de gaulle ont
aujourd'hui
enfin il n'y a pas déjà j'avais eu
d'affaires d'argent de financement de la
vie politique à l'époque et pour cause
il n'y a même pas de journaliste
d'investigation en france ça n'existe
pas le canard enchaîné commencera à
faire de l'investigation sous pompidou
avant c'est un journal satirique
l'ex transfusé n'ont servi que jacques
de rhji bon quand même
il y en a un peu bon admettons mais pas
ce que je veux dire c'est que si on
regardait bien la france du général de
gaulle aujourd'hui en direct une
démocratie autoritaire
on dirait que c'est une démocrature et
je me demande si on regarderait pas le
général de gaulle commande attend ça
regardez vladimir poutine s'était un peu
de tout le régime du général de gaulle
c'est aussi une démocratie parce que les
oppositions vivait alors elle passait
pas par la télévision à la radio et
avait beaucoup de journaux il y avait
une opinion publique vivant en france
dans les années 50 et 60
je ne suis pas sûr que ce soit le cas en
russie je ne pense pas que le pouvoir
laisse vivre l'opinion publique de
gaulle laisser vivre l'opinion publique
mais il maîtrisait la télé la radio et
je pense qu'avec un peu plus
d'investigations je me souviens
notamment de l'affairé ben barka où le
pouvoir gaulliste a été très bousculés
par les journaux de presse écrite très
bousculée ben barka opposant marocain
qui est assassiné à paris en 1966 donc
on ne peut pas tout à fait faire le
parallèle mais c'est vrai que ça n'était
pas une démocratie parfaite et que le
général on a tendance à l'oublier a eu
longtemps avec la république et la
démocratie une relation très distantes
l'obsession du général c'est qu'il y ait
un chef à la tête de l'état après quelle
forme ça prend il a longtemps hésité il
s'est converti à la démocratie en disant
notamment dans les années cinquante à
ses proches que la dictature c'était
bien rodé
mais après ça tournait toujours mal les
dictatures ne s'était pas c'était pas un
rejet de principe
c'était plutôt une analyse intelligente
de ce qu'est une situation d'inconfort
ou de confort donc on ne peut pas dire
que c'était les principes qui guident
est de ce point de vue la réflexion du
général de gaulle donc on peut le
regarder sans doute aujourd'hui avec un
oeil critique
il était plus démocrate que dictateur
quand même je crois
il a été assez sévère avec georges
pompidou à la fin au début il l'adoré il
voulait que ce soit son dauphin à la fin
c'était plus tendu
il s'en est séparé en tant que premier
ministre et puis il n'a pas aimé que le
georges pompidou il déclare sa
candidature avant même le résultat du
référendum parce que d'une certaine
manière c'était dire aux français vous
inquiétez pas si vous dites non au
général je serai là pour 2 pour prendre
la suite
et c'est ce qui s'est passé et il est et
on sait que ce qu'il a pu dire sur le
surplus georges pompidou président de la
république ça n'était pas très gentil
qu'est ce que vous en pensez vous c'est
vrai qu'il était plus conservateur que
le général de gaulle georges pompidou
mais il était quand même d'une
intelligence extraordinaire et
et j'ai l'impression que le recul que là
aussi lui aussi on va se rendre compte
que c'était un grand président ah c'est
possible et c'est possible georges
pompidou en soit c'est un objet de
d'observation intéressant parce que
georges pompidou il est à paris pendant
la guerre il ne résiste pas il ne
collabore pas mais il ne résiste pas non
plus il est d'une impassibilité total et
cet homme de la non résistance en 1944
parce qu'il a des copains de l'école
normale supérieure et qui sont auprès du
général de gaulle commence à travailler
pour le général de gaulle et là entre
les deux il ya quelque chose qui est de
l'ordre de du coup de foudre de gaulle
donnera assez vite à georges pompidou du
mon ami ce qu' il ne fait pratiquement
avec personne et donc les deux hommes
cheminent 20 ans 25 ans ensemble
il faut du temps pour qu'ils se séparent
qu'est ce qui les sépare la vieillesse
c'est que de gaulle s'enfoncer dans une
forme de neurasthénie de déprime de de
pessimisme alors que pompidou est un
petit joyau un petit peu de gay un type
qui pensent que ce qui va arriver est
toujours mieux que se compare on est
pourtant pompidou il a été servi par les
événements donc c'est là dessus qu'ils
se séparent y'a pas de n'y a pas de
divergences politiques mais il y a un
vieux monsieur qui ne supporte plus la
jeunesse de son ami qui n'est plus à
égalité sur le plan biologique
donc ils se séparent et de gaulle écrira
à pompidou que sans sa déclaration que
vous évoquiez à rome un peu rapide sur
wii je suis là pour succéder à de gaulle
site ressemble à de gaulle lui écrit
sans ça j'aurais gagné le référendum en
69 mais de gaulle n'avait pas envie de
gagner le référendum en 69 de gaulle
avait envie d'arrêter sa propre course
mais ils ne savaient plus comment le
faire alors le référendum a été cet
outil là peut-être que les personnages
de cette histoire là n'ont pas
conscience de tout cela quand ils le
vivent
mais quand on regarde nous les
événements avec le recul il est évident
que ce référendum la de gaulle ne
pouvait pas le gagner parce que le mot
d'ordre des et
de mai 1968 était largement partagé dix
ans ça suffit
vous avez été formidables général ciao
et sa de gaulle il a fallu qu'il le
formalise ben le référendum de 1969 a
servi à ça le dernier cadeau du général
c'est le titre du livre de jean michel
aphatie qui vient de paraître chez
flammarion merci jean michel d'avoir
passé toute cette émission avec nous
merci de nous avoir suivis et rendez
vous au prochain numéro
[Musique]